welcome to this video playing at birth
and what the heck did he do with his
rating isn't the same slump as I am
maybe I mean he's really a great player
tears completely wrecked his rating here
strange okay he's going for Kings Indian
type of setup mm-hmm try to remember
there's some line that camp off played a
couple of times with Bishop c5 okay he's
just switching back to her to a ready
type type of approach yeah come on let's
just develop develop pieces
shouldn't be too bad Oh is allowing
Bishop a three that's rare I simply be
probably because the sea porn is a
problem that's the technical thing oh no
it is not that that was not his
intention that's surprising should I
play c5 how my queen is a bit off side
I'll just get it back here I come on why
not it's a he really does not have
anything right against the Queen I think
um okay yeah still I don't think that
justice should be too terrible just
centralized and then see what's what's
going on it takes I can maybe take on d5
and
takes mmm never take with the bishop my
ruckus unprotected here maybe I should
should cover the bishop and kelsey ate
the Queen on a three is not really was
wasn't really doing much anyway so
retreating is probably not bad and came
I take here yeah it feels like a slide a
slight edge for wide yeah still what
else the d6 square is a bit sensitive d6
and c6 but is it really difficult for me
i don't i don't think so wow yeah that's
why it's a good player always in for a
surprise not sure that it is good but
it's a I didn't think about it at all
hmm
hmm Wow 95 to see have any now maybe you
can play hmm if I go to a five Knight
takes Queen d5 that cannot be too bad
Knight takes Queen d5 he needs to play
c3 and if I go if five now what is what
is this response I mean Quint xf3 I mean
night at five let's also take I mean the
exchange cannot be a big problem here
I'm on one minute 32 isn't like just
good here I'm down on time but the
position i mean if i get if i get f 3
with this battery it should be it should
be open really oh yeah on it or not is
got Bishop g2 I forgot about that I can
take a five though
hmm that's not clear at all maybe maybe
after night f5 I I should take measure
takes e4 here I 97 no I must take him no
choice yeah that's that's not clear at
all this is this position what now this
is hanging at 96 but 96 I can take on c2
one minute now look f8 don't want to do
that let's see no alternative though the
other position is probably good I just
adjust the dreaded time the time issue
and it's always easier to play with the
Queen and have little time
trying to get the queen of this dominant
position is investing some time at least
I queen bee to queen bee to coming I can
i can connect rooks now yeah this is
important check check check mate no this
was lucky with 20 seconds on the clock
yeah I guess he's he's in the downward
spiral as well this desire this is a
meeting of two players who usually have
24 or something well at least he is
always higher rated than me normally wow
I am glad to have won against a good
player but very complicated very
complicated stuff how to hard to figure
out that's a revisit some some positions
i was i was astonished that he didn't
take here because I mean here this is
just good for white and then my bishop
III was was a superficial move p.m. I
mean this should probably be okay I mean
for black nothing spectacular but yeah
this is this assistance a cool move
right okay the computer gives queen air
five at the best reply f3 and now 95 it
is giving okay and this is bad okay
night f5 and let's let's consider young
yeah you can yeah you can play a 97
first and then Bishop g2 check and this
is so of course of course very very
messy
come in here and then what 98 Bishop g2
rock GQ rook c8 and what is clearly
better yeah probably possible possible
to to consider all this oops sorry yeah
here black ass the computer just says
black as winning but still you need to
you need to play that Roxy 7s better I
had the suspicion tougher and the 95
getting this night into a pin de this
would have been much better now he got
some some play 95 was good and now i'm
connecting whoops this is super
important check check check I needs to
go back and I'm winning it's minus 5 but
still it would have been difficult with
20 seconds and he's very resourceful but
he ran into this mate thankfully okay
thanks for watching